[Applaudissements]
une finale très serrée c'est 9 et 10
septembre les Cougars de
Montigny-le-Bretonneux en du s'employé
contre les Barracuda de Montpellier à
l'occasion des deux premiers matchs de
la finale du championnat de France de D1
à la sortie de ces deux jours de
compétition les deux équipes repartent
chacune avec une victoire dans leur
valise le samedi Montpellier l'emporte 4
à 3 et le dimanche les inhymontants ont
égalisés en gagnant 3 à 2 là on a eu des
opportunités scorées cette fois on les a
pas laissé passer c'est à dire que quand
il y avait des coureurs en position de
marquer on a été chercher les frappes
qu'il fallait pour les faire rentrer et
puis après encore une fois on défend on
a été vraiment vraiment solide
aujourd'hui on a fait des super jeux à
un moment des jeux des jeux défensifs
qui ont été hyper importants pour pour
ne pas laisser Montpellier marqué donc
non non plutôt aujourd'hui tout s'est
bien tous à bientôt tout s'est bien
tourné pour nous et c'est cool on repart
avec la victoire maintenant place sous
match retour les cougars se rendront ce
samedi 16 et dimanche 17 septembre à
Montpellier pour la suite de ces finales
il faudra gagner deux matchs sur 3 dans
le sud de la France pour soulever la
coupe ça va déplacement compliqué c'est
loin il y a du trajet il fait chaud le
terrain il est pas il est pas il est pas
aussi bien qu'ici là-bas donc ça va être
plein de conditions un petit peu
extérieures qui font que créer des
matchs compliquées mais il faut y aller
un match par un match voilà faire les
petites choses comme on l'a fait
aujourd'hui quand c'est le moment
présent et puis aller chercher la
victoire voilà mon chat prénom et puis
essayer d'aller au bout si les Cougars
de Montigny-le-Bretonneux l'emporte ce
weekend sur le terrain de Montpellier
ils seront champion de France de
première division pour la première fois
de leur histoire